hello winter welcome to this video
playing fantozzi ago okay I am fantozzi
mainline per una which variation at CA
7s one of the moves ticket be sexist
right here we have to memorize quite a
bit down and then the Banco let's go 45
maximum activity it's a very uncommon
structure in the bank you're here but
that the center is is nice and the book
on a seven sometimes can swing over to
the kingside m ok so the 924 time
already hit lets you form let's try
looks a bit shaky in my position size is
why i was a bit reluctant Bishop g5 I
think I 2036
yeah so here I am taking one of two is
probably a bit much so going back to you
50 what you can allow this check come on
that looks risky at best or where's the
tech tech he needs a tactic to justify
that stuff where is the tech tech I
don't see any tactic and then this is
just bad okay so 94 looks like they're
on the move and now we can actually go
to gap seven unless we have something
better a queen age for for example
yeah this is why you play an opening
like the Bangko if things go wrong so go
right they can really write you can get
a completely enormous position after a
couple of moves but Jeff you forget your
stuff or whatever you can get killed
also you forget it or just some songs
you can move you oftentimes some get
into trouble so I think I can take check
and then just attack him especially for
good well it is like resigns yeah we had
a this is a I think yeah this is a
theoretical position and it's extremely
unclear really extremely unclear I mean
it's quite quite them quite quite clear
that black has some compensation for the
pawn is it enough is it more than that
tough the same I'm happy to play this
especially in a quick time control game
so yeah as it is so active I remember
this is something that I look at for my
banco serious it it's this really crazy
position here like it's two pawns down
and he's got fantastic activity you can
just to give a taste them stockfish is
saying equal with the move Bishop h5 but
I mean black has lots of funny a very
nice okay he played this and I went
night you form its kind of typical this
move it has all kinds of ideas sometimes
26 it's a may
the idea i was expecting this and then I
would have gone here not to be six even
though could be six just make some sense
I hear that's not be five okay I hope I
I would have seen that the groupon is
happiness Sabaton uncommon yeah this is
this this is looks good yeah because I
have all kinds of stuff him going on for
me this is very nice okay so this one I
can actually take on f2 I had this
somehow had this hunch that it could
work and you know why it works ha now I
see it it's a bit late they're like this
I just play whatever look at seven or so
and here I can take I can take one of
three ha this is great Queen takes Queen
e1 and pawn takes check you just
probably get that [ __ ] made it somehow
check this check check and you get to
get killed wow so 9f to was already on
yes on tas take only five I guess I mean
it's certainly compensation but check
this is a sound just to win hook like I
think it's too much too much to the
change has helped of course but it was I
think not a defensible position ok guys
thanks for watching